all right now more big breaking news
tonight on our southern border as our
very own sarah carter has an exclusive
hannity investigation revealing the
dangerous reality of human trafficking
and smuggling under the biden border
crisis and she joins us now to explain a
lot more sarah a lot going on down there
oh yeah it surely is sean and it's just
gut-wrenching and heartbreaking you know
as part of an ongoing docu-series
project that i'm working on i spent more
than a week in central america recently
i had the opportunity actually to
interview a human trafficker
it was a very tenuous and kind of
dangerous situation i was hesitant at
first to do the interview although i did
want to find out more information and he
wanted to speak with me
actually because of the number of
children we know hundreds of thousands
of children are being trafficked from
central american from all over the world
into the united states and even this
human trafficker couldn't bear what was
happening to them and that's why you
talked to me i want you to take a listen
to this
what do you do for a living
i am the guy who takes people to the u.s
immigrants to be exact so what made you
decide to do it
i liked to take the risk of doing it and
i knew that people would get a lot of
money out of it
so you have an entire
route
that your organization controls from el
salvador
to the united states
is it easier to traffic the children and
get them in than the adults
it's more risky because once we get to
the cardinals they are asking for
children for them to traffic
with drugs and everything so it's
definitely more risky
what is it that we don't understand what
is it that is so bad about
what is happening like especially when
we think of it like the the trafficking
of human beings the narcotics
that most people just don't understand
in the case of children it really scares
him to just see the reality that they
can go through
and for him it's pretty horrific to see
how they are murdered in many cases are
they just so powerful now that
it's going to be
it was going to result in an all-out war
in an effort to stop it i mean is it
just
are they just so powerful that it's
going to be impossible for any one
person to stop this trouble
there's no way back he they already have
so much power the cartels that he thinks
that it's too late to stop them
sean and there's so much more that he
went into we're going to go into that in
part two coming to you tomorrow but just
on monday a five-year-old girl lost her
life in the rio grande river her mother
was trying to go across the river with
her she was holding her in her arms and
like people warn all the time the
undercurrent was so strong it swept the
young child from her arms another baby
almost drowned that baby is in the
intensive care unit as well here at san
antonio texas in the hospital but i have
to tell you thousands of children
disappear all the time even before they
make it to the rio grande river many of
them will never be found many of them
their names will never be known and when
we bring you that second part tomorrow
it is very disturbing it is very graphic
and there were instances in that
interview i had no idea what was
happening to these children far beyond
the kidnapping far beyond the sexual
predators
i think every american should know
what's happening and that border is not
only a national security risk but it's
abusive and it's a humanitarian crisis
sean